um so i guess going back to the start of
the year
um i would have been a fairly average
typical sort of
30-something dad i would think um
probably stressing a little bit too much
about
work um ferrying the kids around to
clubs all that good stuff
um but i noticed that over christmas i'd
had a an upset stomach and
that didn't seem to be clearing up um i
went to see my gp
he referred me on to uh hospital where i
had a number of tests
uh and in the middle of february very uh
very kindly
uh and strict talking consultant told me
that i had
bowel cancer that it had spread quite
significantly
um and that it was effectively incurable
um
and without any kind of treatment um i
would probably have about nine months
left to live
and you know the family man as well fred
so for you i
i'm presuming that it is all now about
making the most of the time you have
left with your family with your loved
ones and your friends
yeah absolutely um i have two young
children
i have an incredible wife um
you know my parents my brothers it's all
about really trying to
spend as much time as is possible with
them given the various constraints
um that we've had over the last uh over
the last several months
and so you're calling on the government
um and indeed there are others
sharing that crap for uh for you to be
prioritized
a bit higher than than you currently are
in that that priority list what what
would the vaccine though
enable you to do that that you can't do
currently
yeah well you're absolutely right and
it's not just me
asking for this um 12 uh very prominent
charities signed an open letter to the
times
uh last weekend backing uh the points
that i've been making
um when i've been when i've been
speaking to the to the press
um uh really what i'm looking for
um at this stage now is urgently to
um speak with the health secretary matt
hancock
um to get a sense as to okay has
palliative care
and those undergoing palliative care
being properly considered and fully
considered in this vaccine railways
um and does he agree with me um that
there is
uh perhaps a special case in a
humanitarian case
uh for those with terminal illnesses to
be
uh clearly prioritized and so that we
can make the rest
make the most of the rest of uh the time
available to us
um you know listening to your earlier
interview with richard porter and i'm
under no illusions that this means that
life would go
instantly back to normal um for any of
us but
um early vaccination i think would just
firstly enable me to spend more time
with people like my parents
and like my brothers than i'm able to
currently and it would also alleviate a
lot of the day-to-day anxiety that comes
with
small things like doing the school run
going to the supermarket those kind of
essentials
um where actually you know you you feel
in my position where you effectively
don't have a functioning immune system
that you're exposing yourself to a lot
of risk um in in doing those
those fairly uh you know mundane
day-to-day
activities um fred i i we don't
obviously wanted to raise any hopes here
but we did speak a little bit earlier to
the cabinet office minister michael gove
uh he made it pretty clear that actually
yesterday at the highest level of
government
this sort of situation was being
discussed
i just wonder if we can play that to our
viewers just now
it's an incredibly um
you know moving situation when you have
people who are living with terminal
diseases and we're
uh reviewing how we can make sure that
the most vulnerable
and those in clinically difficult
positions can be vaccinated
and we were discussing exactly how we
can do this in government only yesterday
obviously it depends on the number of
vaccines that we can secure but
absolutely when you have um a moving
example like that and and there are all
too many
we want to make sure that people are
vaccinated so they can be
um with those they love uh at what is
inevitably
um an incredibly difficult and stressful
time for for for the family
so so at the very least it is being
discussed fred but i wonder if
you were to have the opportunity to
speak directly to matt hancock
what would this mean to to you and to to
the many others who we shouldn't forget
are and
are in similar situations looking at the
end of their life
and wanting to spend as much time as
possible watch quality time as possible
with those nearest and dearest yeah well
look i mean i think that first of all
that's really encouraging to hear
um but what i'd really like to see more
of is some urgency around this
um there has been some progress um in
scottish parliament
i have to say westminster has been a
tougher nut to crack if i'm honest in
terms of making inroads
and i think partly um the issue is that
people perhaps don't um fully appreciate
the urgency
for people in this kind of a situation
when you do feel that you have a finite
time
left to you the difference of um
say a couple of months in when you get
vaccinated
is actually really really significant
you know that could be a really
significant proportion of what time you
have um what time you have left
available to you
i'll say i'm under absolutely no
illusions that life
won't simply go back to normal um
but nonetheless i think there is
something here that really needs to be
looked at and some issues here that need
to be flushed out um
and were i to uh speak with matt hancock
um i think i'd be saying look what what
consideration
um has gone into this from the from the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunisation
as they've prepared the guidelines and
as i say
does he agree with me uh that there is a
special case here that warrants further
uh investigation and a really rapid
resolution
um fred it's clear to me and i'm sure to
our viewers that you are handling this
with the dignity that many of us would
not be able to possess
um and your priority clearly is your
family i
i'm just wondering as we finish this
interview how they're doing
um they are absolutely remarkable thank
you thank you for asking they
uh they are taking things in their
stride um
i think we recognize there are uh some
difficult days ahead
um but they've been hugely supportive of
what i've been doing
my wife is currently keeping the
children quiet downstairs before taking
them off to school
you know they've been absolutely
fantastic and i couldn't be more proud
of them